[Musique]
2004 c'est une ryder cup dont je me
souviens à plus d'un titre de raison
particulière et personnelle
la première c'est que c'est la première
haider cup à laquelle j'ai assisté en
vrai c'était à dans la banlieue de
détroit à oakland hills et la deuxième
c'est parce que cette édition de la
ryder cup également il y avait un
français le premier français à avoir
jouer la ryder cup 199 gens vont de 20 à
brooklyn et là c'était thomas levet qui
s'était qualifié pour il vient faire le
voyage au sein de l'équipe européenne
cette ryder cup quand on la voit en vrai
c'était déjà un formidable avant coût de
ce qu'on s'apprête à vivre dans quelques
mois au golf national en france
ce qui frappe c'est en le gigantisme de
l'événement encore plus quand on est sur
le sol américain tellement les fans
américains sont déchaînés le public les
médias
l'ambiance très particulière d'une ryder
cup avec ses matches en opposition
directe c'était aussi donc une
découverte pour thomas levet qui pendant
l'épreuve
lui-même se confiait en nous disant j'ai
joué des tonnes de championnat j'ai
remporté des épreuves sur l'european
tour
et pourtant il n'ya pas un événement
comparable en termes de ferveur en
termes d'ambiance en terme d'intensité
et il nous disait lui-même que planter
sa balle sur le tee du 1 en ryder cup il
n'y avait pas d' expérience comparable
dans toute sa carrière de sportif
professionnel donc une saveur
particulière à plus d'un titre
couronné aussi par une nouvelle victoire
de l'équipe
européenne à l'issue des trois jours de
compétition
[Musique]